[Aplausos]
[Música]
la mayoría de las veces cuando las
personas piensan en los problemas que
tenemos las chicas de mi edad más o
menos al crecer se imaginan en el
clásico ay no sé qué ponerme o no tengo
el celular o el maquillaje más nuevo
pero déjenme decirles que esos no son
todos los problemas que tenemos hay un
millón de cosas que son mil veces más
graves que eso aunque sí a veces
exageramos alguna que otra cosa
yo no quiero hacerlo sentir culpables
por nosotras tampoco quiero que piensen
que será una chica es lo peor del mundo
tampoco quiero que piensen que estamos
mal por ser chicas pero sí quiero que
entiendan que cuando su compañera les
contesta mal no es solo porque está en
sus días o que cuando su hija vuelve a
estresada a casa del colegio no es sólo
por ese 6 en el examen de matemática
uno de los factores por las que la
mayoría de las chicas se frustran es con
el tema de la estética
la mayoría de los que están acá alguna
vez escucharon hablar de 90-60-90 para
los que no saben qué es esto
estas son las medidas perfectas que una
mujer debería tener estos son 90
centímetros de busto 60 centímetros de
cintura y 90 centímetros de cadera sólo
una minoría de las chicas tienen estas
medidas y hay un montón de mujeres que
siguen muy estrictas dietas solo para
tenerlas y muchos terminan haciéndose
mal a ellas mismas pero todo para ser
perfectas
otro factor es que tenemos que estar
perfectamente depiladas pero este es un
factor menor no
total es muy poco tiempo de nuestras
vidas gastado para ver los más lindas no
claro porque de cuidarnos las piernas el
cavado las axilas y a veces hasta
incluso los brazos nos lleva dos minutos
está obviamente la respuesta es la hoja
está en el lleva aproximadamente media
hora un día sí y un día no pero el
tiempo que gastamos de tirándonos no es
lo peor sino que lo peor es el por qué
lo hacemos no me malinterpreten yo
también me depilo pero al principio no
tenía muy en claro por qué las chicas se
depilaban osea nos ponemos eran las
piernas y terminamos llorando o nos
pasamos la gillette y nos cortamos todas
solo para no tener pelos y claro la
ingenua ámbar de 11 años no sabía que si
no lo hacemos damos asco
la gente piensa que es desagradable pero
una chica caminando por la calle toda
peluda y que si piensa en vivir así que
se tapen no tenemos por qué verlas así
creo que se dieron cuenta de que yo no
piensa así pero si no piensa así
entonces porque me depilo
al principio yo me intentaba auto
convencer de que era incómodo tener
pelos decía tienen el pelo por la
cintura pero llegué a la conclusión de
que no lo hago por lo que piense yo de
mí misma luego por lo que piensen los
demás de mí o por lo que podrían llegar
a decir de mí
este es un tema que yo nunca lo llegué a
hablar ni con mis papás ni con mis
amigas pero no es que no lo hable por lo
que pueda llegar a pensar de mí porque
estas son personas que siempre me van a
querer y siempre me van a apoyar pero
nunca lo hable porque estos temas son
tabú como también lo es la menstruación
literalmente le pedí a varios chicos de
mi clase que escriban la palabra
menstruación y no la sabía ni escribir
aparte de que me miraron con cara de
como si fuese la rara y algunos me
preguntaron hasta qué era eso pero bueno
la cosa es que muchas chicas no saben
del tema hasta que les viene por primera
vez se asustan y le dicen a sus mamás a
veces hasta nos da cosita decir estoy
menstruando y en vez de eso decimos ahí
no me puedo meter a la pileta porque
estoy con andrés
o porque estoy con la regla o estoy
presente
también muchas veces en publicidades de
marcas de toallitas femeninas
muchas veces muestran un líquido azul
derramado en la toallita y pocas veces
uno rojo discúlpenme pero cuando yo y
faye menstrual del mito allí está le
encuentro nada a solucionar yo rojo o
soy la única rara que no ve nada azul
también en las publicidades désilets
siempre son chicas jóvenes ya depiladas
depilándose y diciendo lo bueno que es
el producto cuando de seguro pagaron una
fortuna para depilarse con láser
también en las publicidades de bebés o
nenes de menos de 4 años casi siempre
son las mamás las que aparecen y muy
pocas veces los papás
y esto es porque desde que somos muy
chicas estamos predestinados a ser
madres
literalmente una amiga siempre dijo yo
quiero ser mamá esas cosas a mí no me
interesan esto lo dijo a los 7 años y
sigue pensando lo mismo pero claramente
es la gente en vez de meterse en su
propia vida y dejar que el resto tome
sus propias decisiones le dijieron hay
buenos ya vas a cambiar de opinión
cuando seas más grande pero claro al
nene de 7 años que dice que no quiere
ser astronauta y quiere ser abogado no
le dice nada
también las chicas tenemos que crecer
con todo está en la cabeza
crecemos pensando que nuestro objetivo
en la vida es ser mujer y que si no es
ser mamá y que señalarla cumplís no
estás cumpliendo con su propósito
crecemos pensando que estar menstruando
es algo malo que por lo que hay que
estar avergonzados y no decirle a nadie
crecemos sabiendo que somos unas rev
azil es por subir una foto en bikini a
instagram
todos estos son factores que nos alteran
son factores que nos van diciendo a
quién tenemos que ser cómo nos tenemos
que vestir y hasta con qué clase de
gente nos tenemos que juntar
son factores que si no lo seguís la vas
a empezar a pasar mal te van a empezar a
burlar en el colegio y vos por ahí le
has a pedir ayuda a alguien y la ayuda
que te van a dar es decirte que los
ignores ignorar que te juzguen por no
tener las piernas depiladas ignorar que
te miren mal es cuando decís que no te
puedes meter a la pileta porque están
menstruando ignorar que te digan que eso
es re fácil por subir una foto en bikini
a instagram pero déjenme decirles que no
son los que les dicen
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]